hello welcome to the Australian
commentary for a happy deathday happy
deathday to you happy deathday the top
of the dose Stevie Wonder come on happy
birthday Oh Ron Harris
dinner'll that was welcomed to the
Australian deaf day the show about the
show that you hopefully just watch which
was the honest trailer for happy
deathday mmm and if you stick around at
the end you'll see some deleted scenes I
think one or two we got we got we got oh
yeah starring double yeah yeah well I
hope we have a lot because I personally
don't have too much to say about this
film I thought it was nice I thought it
was pretty close to the Groundhog Day
formula but they did some fun things
with it and I was pleased and then the
movie ended yeah I think I might I think
my one big issue is that they should
deal with the groundhog Danis earlier
like leaving it for the end just leaves
you the whole movie like why doesn't
anybody bring up that her situation
oh you mean literally saying Groundhog
Day I think if you're gonna acknowledge
it at all like there's a version of this
where you don't acknowledge it you're
just like this is a universe where
Groundhog Day doesn't exist right fine
but if you're going to acknowledge it
don't save it for the very end that just
feels like a cop-out yeah to be fair
everyone else was catching up on it
except for her establish that Carter is
a movie buff he's got like repo man
posters very old he's got yeah he's a
young kid but with 80s the same taste as
like a late 30s screenwriter but but he
would know grandpa like right away oh
you're doing a Groundhog Day and then
they could have played with that and
been like try what Phil Connors I would
just feel like get it out of the way
earlier so I'm not like left the whole
movie wondering if you're gonna wear
dress
yeah and you look you can pick apart
some things in this film like when she's
crossing names off her list I'm not sure
how she's actually ruling people out as
the killer
I think she's she's investigating she's
doing her sisters her investigations
yeah but like she finds out that like
one guy's gay so she's like well he
couldn't be the killer
oh and gay could be I think she got
killed right after that didn't she
wasn't she looking in his window and
then she immediately was killed it's
like well it's not him then because the
rules are a little bit vague because you
can it it's either find the killer and
then you're out of the loop or it's just
lived through the night and then you're
out of loop it was never quite clear
this doesn't bother me as much because
you wouldn't if you were stuck in a
groundhog day you wouldn't know you
would just be guessing like well I
wonder how I get out of this loop like
that's what people Connors is doing and
Groundhog Day first he's like suicide
and he's like I just have to be a good
person and help everybody it's not until
the end he realizes like oh wow the
storm or whatever was containing him was
kind of prevented him from trying some
different things where I could have just
booked a one-way ticket to Mexico like
on day three yeah loop and that's the
question is it like final destination
where somehow the baby-faced was always
after her yeah yeah they didn't figure
out like is there a cold front coming in
from Altoona they didn't bother to do
that part we will be digging more into
this in happy deathday to you yes there
I saw in some of the ads they're
promising to go into the lower and
explain some of this which whatever the
filmmaker did say I remember reading
this before the first one even came out
that they had a plan if they got to do a
sequel that would explain why she's in a
time right which is what we all want in
their back pocket the whole time
is there like the original version of
Groundhog Day doesn't get like cursed or
something like me like hits a witch it's
like seriously there's like a there's an
execution and also like it goes on like
falling in love doesn't work either and
eventually he just like attains Buddhist
enlightenment no that's much worse yeah
no we got the final the final scene in
the original Groundhog Day I believe is
he's sitting on the bed like meditating
with his eyes open as the clock turns
over and the song starts playing again
so it's like he's no state where he's
moved beyond time hmm cool not as good
not as good snowman with Andie MacDowell
so yeah I'm not sure exactly why we did
this movie probably cuz the sequels
coming out and I did well I advocated
for this yeah this sounds cynical but
it's because it was a popular film and I
felt like there would be an audience
that wasn't that might want us to do it
because the classics that we do that we
used to do like six years ago like the
clothes this will be a huge view getter
yeah those are not classics really to
necessarily everyone not the kids like
plus I had ultimate faith honestly you
and Joe and lawn that you could crack I
liked the direction we took yeah this is
interesting creative challenge which at
this point without his trailers is nice
to be able to do something different
like a different approach and I was I
think you guys did a good job of this
well there you go
thank you Dan let's roll it happy
deathday to us from the studio
that's a conjuring away from making all
the horror movies comes a film that at
first glance looks like a slasher
version of Groundhog Day
but then in a surprise twist is Gilbert
is sitting so weird that should come a
jumper question pause we got all that
well who's who who cracked the idea of
doing the same run over and over again
was it us probably joke it was Joe yeah
doing the loop and then we add on a
little something right we sort of layer
in the joke as you keep going back
through the trailer that I believe that
was in Joe's original concept yeah no
yeah so yeah I agree all credit to
Joestar thank you John John Bailey for
it's a bit of an acting challenge it was
yeah yeah this is a bit more performance
heavy than some of the other stuff
John's done yeah yeah yeah
John had some stuff came up and he had
to record it late on my drive home and I
couldn't and he was breaking up so I was
basically biscuit guessing that he was
doing it or doing it right and it turned
out he did yeah oh and shout out to our
editors and one of them TJ who is one of
the two main editors that works in
honest trailers not dead not dead but he
has gone to work on some documentary
stuff and so Thank You TJ thank you last
trailer TJ worked on
thank you sister Swan sighing yeah
yes terrific work yeah it's great one to
go out on so yeah let's keep going the
kind that starts with waking up next to
this goober oh hey and ends with being
murdered by a psycho in a baby mask that
you'll have to relive over and over
again until she discovers who the killer
is and stops being such an a-hole how
does it only last week and makes peace
with her estranged father stop you
paused it pause no sir that's another
thing I thought about this movie like
Groundhog Day he's he's a jerk to people
but it's also like he's Bill Murray we
have a built-in affection for Bill
Murray and he's like funny like we are
laughing at the one-liners I in this one
it took me longer to sort of come around
a tree because she's she's objectively
awful for the first film yeah she's not
good
yeah great performance though yeah I
really liked Jessica um I thought she
was great in this role really
charismatic and I never I didn't
remember seeing her in anything before
no this is the only thing I think I know
her from but yeah like in the second and
third act she does a really good job of
humanizing tree I think but yeah in the
beginning it's really took me a while to
be like I don't dislike because she's
totally playing like one of the first
people to get killed off in a horror
movie but actually kind of evolves into
yeah into the lead um yeah yeah good job
keep going a tree gilman is having the
worst PA ever discovered yeah as a
character in twist Theresa
oh and Ed's with being murdered by a
psycho in a baby mask that you'll have
to relive Oh about when then we play
some clips of her being mean originally
really sorry originally in the comments
yeah originally he went he went through
it I think two or three times before he
had the first like wait a minute and
like I think we'd sort of tightened it
subsequent drafts yeah and then yeah
just charting his emotional journey of
like scared - frustrated - at peace yeah
yeah you don't need to repeat it that
many more times sure I
I will say as a former editor like who
was always trying to get from the
beginning to the end of these things as
quickly as possible as far as pace goes
I initially was going to recommend
cutting down the clips of her being mean
he was like do we need all three and I
like typed out the note the first time I
watched the trailer through and then I
realized that that was not a good idea
because it needed to be a little bit
long because then when you replay it it
plays and then also later when we go
back through and they shorten the
shorten it works better so that was a
nice trick this is nice again nice
editing job from Kevin and yeah really
sinking our teeth whoa Brandi who helped
us finish this episode enamine as always
yeah we really stand on the shoulders of
giants
look look for our coffee table book the
art of honest race coming in a few
months people watch the show yeah edge
of tomorrow my self I mean happy
deathday myself last time you big day no
no three Gilman is having the worst
birthday ever
goober underclassman okay stupid baby
mask same scenes over and over focus you
can figure this out maybe talking about
the characters will help and she'll
break out with some help from Carter who
clears the world's lowest bar to become
her dream guy I didn't take advantage of
last night okay together that milkshake
shot I was speaking of editing yet going
back over when you watch the movie again
like a second or third time as I have it
takes forever she walks over slowly and
then slowly tilts the milkshake like the
other it's telegraphed yet she would
have had so Danielle would have had so
long to react and get out of the way or
knock it out of the way and just feel
like Stan's their backgrounds loving it
too I really felt
I really feel for that actors having to
sell like shocked even though let's do a
little bit of extra work there because
from that angle he could not really
really happen
oh no you did sorry I just love I love
watching extras yeah don't look at the
camera sir all right keep going Peter
what time are you going to deposit
[Music]
and solve the mystery of who's trying to
kill her or I guess just survive into
the next day did I get it right
okay please work please work the girl
tree Gilman is having the worst she
wakes up next to the heroic non rapist
Carter oh and has to unmask this baby
face or get another pg-13 friendly dead
and she better do it quick because while
this villain may look like a baby he
moves like a really fast baby past him
we didn't really talk about how perfect
frame it's a really one of the worst
college mascots of all time yeah go baby
yeah baby hey I might know it was that I
I can only assume that they named them
the babies so that their opponents said
it awful just like yeah stomp those made
those baby yeah yeah we're gonna crap
out of those babies you a bunch of baby
killers like otherwise yeah that's a
terrible mascot yeah it could be like
you know like it's a baby but like I
think it's got another level to it you
know like there's my sorry what there's
the Fighting Irish that's not just like
a little man that's like there's a
there's a concept to it you know or like
the Blue Devils or something like that
but it is actually a little like a man
yeah I don't know how it still is but it
is fighting baby baby treat babies it's
not no it really isn't it's just babies
it says it's really okay I didn't
realize it just said no it is not you
know the agro babies or the baby Devils
are right that's what I was thinking
it's like well maybe it's like New
Year's babies if they feel babies I
think very convenient creepy creepy
killer mask weird mascot it'd be like if
it screamed they went to like the you
know the the Georgetown ghosts faces
yeah it seems a little too weird at
slash convenient it's interesting you
brought that up this mask was actually
designed by the same guy who designed
the ghost face mask for scream i I saw
that during my research for this I did
not find this mask that effective though
it's scary it doesn't ever get creepy
it's just it just looks too much like a
baby else a little goofy like a little
Popeye ish I went to Halloween Horror
Nights it's pretty creepy
what happen out here in the dark if it
was chasing me I would feel differently
yeah
thank you go a slasher with cardio well
that's really his revolutionising horror
boom nailed it treed gulping son of a
[ __ ]
okay let's be rational about this she
had to become less of an a-hole to
escape so maybe I have to be less mean -
well fine I'll say it I like this film
all right look the setup isn't original
but overall it's fun and Jessica Roth is
great okay so if you like entertaining
slasher films I don't take themselves
too seriously
with enough twists to keep you guessing
maybe check out happy deathday there
that was a note from me yeah because I
think John originally has scripted John
said definitely go see just said go see
happy deathday and while it was not paid
advertising and and would not be it felt
like we were advertising so yeah if that
sounds weird that's cuz I put in the
note like can we soften that a little
bit so it doesn't sound like they paid
us to say go for be happy that day no
money for happy death day none what so
now it's just Marvel the only one paying
us is Disney I wanna make that clear
I'm playing all sides off each other I
get checks from all three really yes
Warner Disney and sony Sony what about
Fox yes that's the same thing now
anymore soon yeah so I just uh they all
pay me and I have negative opinions
about all of them it's great Wow yeah
nice work if you can get it yeah I know
- Chang had no idea let's finish up the
right size when's the last time you saw
an appropriately-sized or room in a
movie huh sure
[Music]
starring yes we made make like a tree
and be
nice guy even his past for Richie
DeGeorge
[Music]
back and forth on the Brecon there was a
lot of back and forth I think that looks
just like first of all it does
if I were picturing a college-age Brett
Kavanaugh physically he resembles it and
it's the concept of we try not to take
political sides but we also can't ignore
things that happen and it would since it
seemed like a funny I think we all know
what it refers to regardless of your
feelings about the specifics of more
about the idea of a crazy frat boy who
is completely indifferent to the obvious
distress
yeah of some of that situation I would
say yeah I like beer
that guy poof's yeah he was hanging out
with skinny Tommy and Slater is ya know
I'm sure people will get angry but I
know we talked about it and we thought
that it's he's on the Supreme Court now
he can take a little bit of honest
trailers okay yeah anyways keep going he
can literally sue us I guess Cupcake
Wars and I really like how we did the
well ferocity yeah how's your down it's
another achievement in awkward like I
dance I dance up with armie hammer and
Oscar my same time really long and when
Oscar Isaac wins that dance off the tow
here sure yeah more practice the other
ones are more improvising I mean he's
got some moves though he's no slouch arm
yeah yeah this guy's definitely dead
last yeah and then put are me and Oscar
against each other yeah this guy's
easily outclassed yeah well congrats you
made it let's watch them deleted scenes
story got another teen murderer
tree Pete remember to remember
I agree that ends well really fresh in
the dirt he's a little it wins oh crap
oh crap oh gamma meanest girl marijuana
not even ones because you'll get stabbed
by a ball back in time Selena Gomez
doggy and a great choice for killers
mask put a horrible choice for a college
mascot she's gonna want to play for the
babies groundhogs way yeah so I didn't
make it in there you go
yeah well that's every thought I've ever
had about happy yeah yeah what about you
guys to you the one thing I will say is
I liked a thing it looks like they're
gonna do more in the sequel that I liked
in this one is when she wakes up she's
got like the residual effects of how she
was killed they don't use it as much as
maybe they should in this one but it
looks like they're gonna hit it that was
starting an interesting twist on the
Groundhog Day fertilis she couldn't die
infinite times that was like a ticking
clock of like she has scar tissue and
it's to figure it out or else she's
gonna yeah and I just like like if she
got hit on the head she wakes up with a
headache if she drowns she spits up
water like that's a fun sort of gimmick
they they couldn't play around with it
in a pg-13 way without being like gross
yeah so you know in the tradition of
audiences wanting the same thing they've
seen a million times before but
different mm a qualified it's the same
but different
I'm excited for it because I really
liked I saw the first one Oh for the
sequel you know the sequel oh yes sorry
yeah you're excited I'm excited okay
yeah I like the first woman after
revisiting this I'm definitely gonna
want to check out the minute the new one
yeah oh and surprising you know like a
like a teen college pg-13 horror movie
not really my jam but but I like this
film I think you would too if you
watched it and I hope you enjoyed this
honest trailer Deafness honest trailer
commentary you gots to come back because
we've been training a long time for this
next week long time really a lot of
training training for the Polar Express
[Laughter]
you
[Music]